[Music]
I'm going to tell you about recent
progress in deep learning and that
relates to AI and I think where I see
some of the current limitations
suggesting path for the future towards
creating human-level AI I'm not going to
tell you about when some kind of magical
event is going to happen because I don't
think it's reasonable to make these
predictions but we can discuss it this
afternoon so there's been a lot of
breakthroughs thanks to deep learning
over the last few years it started with
speech recognition then some really big
progress in computer vision in both of
these cases we now have benchmarks on
which train systems do as well as humans
they're still worse than humans in many
ways but that's giving you a measure of
the progress that has happened recently
there's been pretty amazing progress in
machine translation I'll say a few words
about that as an example of recent
progress although it didn't really yet
turn into industrial products there's
been pretty amazing progress in our
ability with neural nets to move into
the areas of reasoning attention and
memory and that's that's nothing
interesting for the future because the
ol Nets had been thought for many
decades to be limited to things like
pattern recognition and now we're really
moving into the kinds of things which
more classical AI have been tackling
over the last few decades of course
there's been a lot of progress in
reinforcement learning playing games go
and so on and what some of you maybe
don't know is the progress that has been
recently in robotics and control I think
we're just seeing the beginning of that
and one area which is really an
application but
more something underlying a lot of
applications which is progress with
recurrent Nets and very deep nets which
allow us to better handle sequential
data and and potentially handle
abstractions as I'll mention that the
end better so as an example for this
that I've chosen because we've worked on
this for a few years the use of
attention and machine fronting and its
application to machine translation so in
machine translation with deep learning
one one very basic idea that we've had
for many years but but by itself isn't
enough is that we're going to be
learning a mapping from text in some
language to some kind of universal
presentation which you can think of the
meaning of a sentence and then we're
going to decode that back into another
language the problem with that approach
is that as the length of the sentences
or the paragraphs grows this doesn't
make any sense which I have to compress
say a whole document into a fixed time
vector that's kind of crazy that's not
the way we do it if I translate a book I
am going to sort of keep track of where
I am in the source book as I transition
to than the output book that I'm
translating and this is what attention
is used for here we have a kind of soft
pointer in the source so to where
approximately I'm currently doing my
translation and that little idea which
is of course inspired by how humans do
things has been having a big impact for
machine translation but also in other
areas like reasoning and memory and
handling data structures with with
neural nets which is one of the recently
very active areas to measure the effect
of that it's interesting to look at a
little bit of how things progressed so
when we started working on machine
translation about three years ago our
initial results were dismal much worse
than the state of the art and you slowly
you know slowly made progress
eventually we we stumble them upon this
soft attention thing which really made a
big difference but but even then
we reach the state-of-the-art of
previous technique may be beating them
on on a few language pairs but more
recently Google has brought that to the
Google scale and and obtained for the
amazing reach also this these members
are coming from just a few weeks ago a
couple of months ago and we they now
have systems trained on datasets that
are bigger than any one human can have a
chance to see in their lifetime but that
that essentially approach human level
performance in terms of machine
translation as far as other humans
looking at the translation area bill
display so each of these columns looking
well each of these each of these columns
corresponds to some score given by
humans looking at translations the
quality and the ppm T is the traditional
phrase based machine translation GMT is
Google neural machine translation and
human is how humans rate other humans
and you see that we have we've closed
the gap quite a lot so I don't want to
spend too much time on this but still
let you know that the the promised
breakthrough in machine translation that
we were hoping a couple of years ago has
happened all right so now let me say
quickly a few words about why I believe
that deep learning is working so well
and for that I want to step back a
little bit about you know what I see is
the ingredients for a machine learning
moving forward in terms of approaching
AI and I see the following ingredients
at least and probably more but is really
basic for that purpose so one is first
that you have to realize that you know
to build intelligent machine that
machine will need a lot of knowledge and
so the basic question of the Ilia is how
do we get all that knowledge into the
machine and and in order to do that with
machine learning that means that that
knowledge is going to come mostly from
data which means
there's going to be a lot of knowledge
and we need a lot of data all right
that's sort of very basic and you know
whether it's supervised learning or NIST
revised or enforcement you know lots of
knowledge equals lots and lots of data
the other thing is of course in order to
capture all of that information we need
very very flexible model not the kind of
simple Primerica models that used to be
very common for example untinted istic
s-- and in many machine learning model
but that's not okay so so then the other
thing is that goes with that is
obviously to train those models that are
going to be big join a lot of data we
need enough computing power and one of
the reasons for the recent success of
course is we've had GPUs and I see this
moving forward very fast in the next few
years with industry putting a lot of
money in building specialized hardware
for a neuron that one little other point
that many people don't think much about
is and that's one of the advantages of
using your necks in their current form
is that you can go from question to
answer very quickly so that's what we
call computationally efficient inference
that's not the Susilo tree of of any
machine learning approaches and in
general in fact if you were to try to
solve us your questions from knowledge
acquired from data you would think that
you need exponential computation to
answer many questions so essentially
these these methods use some kind of
approximate answering systems that that
are very efficient are trained and
trained that way but the most important
point for why deep learning is is
working so well is that it incorporates
that the my point number five it
incorporates assumptions about the world
that happen to be reasonable and work
well for for the kind of task that we
want to do with AI and these assumptions
you can think of them as priors that
help us defeat the curse of
dimensionality to some extent so let me
elaborate on that a little bit the basic
assumptions that deep learning is making
about the world is one of
compositionality so you know just as we
use compositionality and understanding
the world
in engineering solutions to problems in
language we need to use this idea that
we can both understand and answer
questions about the world by composing
pieces together that's something that
comes naturally in deep nets in two ways
and they're kind of parallel way and a
sequential way the power way is the idea
of distributor representations the fact
that we're going to represent percepts
or states of the world or thoughts by
composition of features or attributes
that are not mutually exclusive that's
the idea of feature learning that I'm
going to explain a bit more in the next
slide and then of course the depth part
the idea that these features are going
to be composed by vvd existing by
composing together features at lower
levels and we can do that at multiple
levels of the hierarchy that's kind of
sequential way of composing things and
both of these turn out to be useful so
to understand a little bit the part
about distributed representations and
why this buys you a kind of exponential
advantage statistically think about the
problem of analyzing images of people
and and and let's assume that we tryna
known that that at some level of
representation extracts features
attributes of those images but of course
these attributes are not going to be
predefined are going to be discovered by
the machine and think about as an
example that maybe some unit is going to
discover that whether or not a person
wears glasses another one the person is
either male or female other one that the
person is a child and so on and it
doesn't have to be those clear semantic
attributes but you can think of them
like like that in general if you think
about all of the configurations of these
attributes if you had you had 100
attributes each of them is a binary you
would have two to the hands with
configurations of images that you'd like
to characterize by these attributes
and there's not going to be enough
training data to cover all of those
cases so the magic here is that we're
able to generalize from a small subset
of these configurations to new
configurations and the reason we are
able to generalize without having to
look at all the configurations is that
we can essentially learn about each of
these attributes without having to see
all the values of the other attributes
so like detecting that a person wears
glasses you don't need to see all of the
configurations of whether the person is
male or female or person is a child or
not or what's the color of their hair
what kind of dress they're they're
wearing in order to figure out you know
whether in the image we are seeing
glasses being wear so that's true for
many of these attributes and that means
that the number of parameters and the
number of examples grows something like
linear with a number of attributes not
exponentially as if you were using more
classical nonparametric methods that
that people are being using like kernel
methods which would in principle require
an exponentially large number of of
examples to cover all these cases ok so
so that's all nice but I think we're
still very far from human level AI I
think there may be there's too much hype
about AI these days as can be read in
the press at least and we underestimate
some of the hard problems that are in
front of us that's what I believe so for
one thing all of the industrial
successes we've seen are based on pure
supervised learning for the most part
and another problem is that the way that
our current state-of-the-art systems
generalize it's still very very
simple-minded I think that our current
learning systems rely on superficial
clues in in the data that do not
necessarily generalize well outside of
training contexts and that means we can
easily fool those systems if we if we
think about it
those systems really pick on surface
regularities like like the color of
things and
and dominant dominant signals like
what's the what's the background of the
image if it's if there's a lot of
greenery then it's going to think that
there's an animal even though there
really isn't so so one thing I'll be
arguing about and that I'm pushing in my
own research is trying to think more
about how we can train agents to learn
and discover high-level abstractions and
that often is going to need to think
also about multiple time scales which is
connected to this idea of learning long
term dependencies that is dear to my
heart another technical thing is we are
still relying a lot on one very old
recipe which is back prop that requires
smooth differentiable predictors which
isn't exactly what we need and this is
another topic of current research so we
need to do a lot better in terms of
unsupervised learning humans are very
good at n supervised learning for
example a two-year-old understands
intuitive civics even though her parents
have never told her about you turn
Newtonian physics and differential
equations and we've had many years of
research on deep unsupervised learning
but but all of the methods we have
currently have some limitations I'm not
going to have the time to go into all of
these things in the case of both
machines it has to do with the problem
of mixing between modes we've had a lot
of success recently with auto regressive
models but I think it's it's not going
to bring us to the next stage because
these models don't learn really abstract
representations with latent variables
we've had lots of recent success with
things like relational auto-encoders and
generative adversarial networks again
and this is the current frontier but
they're kind of hard to train and still
unsatisfactory in terms of learning and
discovering abstraction but but still
let me show you some of the progress
this is the kind of sample we were
getting a about two years ago with with
gas
so good four digits not so good for
natural images this is how it was about
a year ago and these are still kind of
were specialized to one category and and
this is how it is now
so this is generating images of
volcanoes these are not real images
these are generated by the computer and
it can generate any of the 1000 images
at categories so this looks impressive
but it's still very stupid in some ways
so what's missing so as I as I mentioned
I think a lot more research in making
computer learning more autonomous and as
provides learning is a crucial element
of that one thing I think we haven't
really focused enough is how to discover
underlying causal factors this isn't
something that machine learning is
paying too much attention to one one
thing that several of us believe is
going to be important but doesn't work
yet as model-based reinforcement
learning which with coupled with much
more powerful unsupervised learning
would allow us to deal better with
completely new situations so if you
think about self-driving cars
there'll be really observed the
dangerous states that we have to deal
with and our current approaches are not
going to be able to generalize through
these things so we need to have systems
that can imagine a future corresponding
to states that are very far from the
ones that it has seen during training
because these states could be very
important for its in terms of reward
will lead progress and computational
power but I think that's that's going to
happen in the next few years and decades
we need to make progress in handling
multiple time scales there's going to be
progress in understanding language but I
think at some point if we don't make
progress in our ability to discover and
represent high level abstractions we're
going to hit we hit a wall there one
thing I want to mention is that we could
very well have if we wanted an AI which
is passive that understands the world
really well I mean it's going to take
some time before we get there but then
that wouldn't have much significant
influence in the world
however of course once we start having
intelligent machines we want to use them
not just to answer questions but also to
do things to be active and that of
course raises interesting questions
about the reward system and one of the
questions that I'm interested in is how
do we learn human values I think that's
how do we train away wise AI so yeah I
had a last bit my last line about using
action acting in the world to guide
representation learning so this is a new
idea that I started working on to try to
tackle the question of what is a good
representation and how do we go further
in this direction that I've been pushing
for many years of discovering and
disentangling underlying factors of a
lot of explanatory factors that explain
the data which is still too vague and
one idea is that if you have agents
acting in the world they can they can
act in such a way that they can control
some of those factors so so the
functions corresponding to things that
can be controlled are obviously
important causal elements of the world
and we could potentially use this to to
disentangle some of the underlying
explanations about the world alright so
I'm going to stop here and show you a
picture of people in my lab and thank
you very much for those who don't know
me my name is youngish Mutulu from the
swiss AI lab and thank you for this
interesting presentation I was wondering
you mentioned these long term
dependencies and examples like speech
recognition and language translation and
at the heart of these current current
models at least currently there's always
this long short-term memory for who grew
which is making these predictions for
speech recognition on your cell phones
and so on
for the language translation and and
these models can deal with pretty long
long-term dependencies sometimes even
thousands of steps or even millions in
certain isolated cases so I was
wondering how far do you think is it
important to go back in time and what is
the main thing that is missing in the
existing models so it's true that we're
doing a lot better than we were doing in
the early 90s in terms of long term
dependencies but in practice we do see
still even using lsdm and all of the
techniques we currently have problems in
which the long term dependencies escape
because of the learner and I think one
of the interesting potential
explanations for this is the training
objectives that we are optimizing so
typically we optimize something like
like you'd and what happens would like
you it is that like you'd give as much
weight to all of the bits in the data
the unfortunate thing is that a lot of
the really interesting bits are these
high-level abstract things so if you
think about speech raw acoustic speech
it has lots and lots of bits that are
detailed of the acoustics and very few
bits that have to do with the words and
their meaning and so when we do nice of
like skewed and and these of course
happen at the slow scale well right so
so even though on simple toy problems we
can we can do these things of you know
learning long term dependencies when we
go to more realistic problems like
dealing with language what we find is
that the learners actually only capture
fairly short term dependencies and
things get much much worse if instead of
working at the word level you work at
the acoustic level which where the time
scale is out sixteen thousand per second
so I think there's still a lot to do in
that respect and you are not optimistic
that one can just hope to solve that by
getting another factor of ten in terms
of kids of computing power every five
years which means in 25 years you will
have
roughly a brain no no because it's not a
I don't think yeah I think there's just
an overwhelming effect here but gal
could be wrong the some some of us in
academia have some concerns about how
the relationship between arson industry
and how that needs to change would you
like to comment on that yes I think
there's been a lot of positive that has
happen in that respect in the sense that
industry is doing a lot more basic
research right now they used to in AI
that being said of course there's a
danger of the you know the bride of
people going to industry and not having
enough teachers and research happening
in academia I think this may be a
temporary problem and by the number of
grad students that we're training and
others are training right now I think in
the next three to four years hopefully
we'll have enough faculty for doing the
job but yeah it is a concern I don't
suppose you you spoke about
compositionality yes and I think we now
have pretty rigorous theorems
essentially the most rating that if the
conjecture you had long ago is correct
this brings up some interesting
philosophical questions because the
theorem says that deep networks can
avoid the curse of dimensionality for
certain classes of bugs right and the
second part is often forgotten by some
people and this schedule functional
compositional function right it's like
what the visual system does neurons that
look at local parts of the image and
then neurons that local locally look at
the output of the previous neurons from
area to area so the total computations
are local and the question is this is a
debate to is max max tegmark here the
fact that so many problems we deal with
seems to be compositional is that
because our brain works that way or
because the physics of the world ah
looks that way that's a really
interesting question I have started a
little bit about it
so here's what I think I think our brain
works that way it uses those principles
and so we are able to solve those
problems in the world that that have
those properties and there may be other
things that are escaping us because our
brain isn't able to deal with those with
them so my view and I'll talk more about
this in my talk tomorrow is that the
neocortex is organized hierarchically
it's actually a hierarchy of sequential
models and the sequential models are not
lsdm they don't deal with long term
dependencies that's dealt with by the
hierarchy and that deals with
compositionality and also deals with the
sort of intricate interactions at
different levels of abstraction that we
find that the N ends can do that
incidentally to some extent but I'll
talk about some of the work we're doing
where we can significantly outperform L
of TMS in terms of this type of
abstraction but I think that ultimately
a lot of the problems we're saying will
be solved by using a hierarchy of
sequential models so we hear a question
I agree I think I think having a
hierarchy at indifferent in many
different ways so in space and time in
abstraction all of these things are
important and we've been pushing these
boundaries for several years I think
much more needs to be done still thanks
time for one more question
okay so I'm for more formal question
apparently oh girl you
the biggest surprise that's on your talk
was the little line at the bottom of one
slide that said maybe we need methods to
learn ethics yes the reason I was
surprised as I couldn't imagine what the
objective would be since the Nets line
on your slide was people don't agree on
this can well every yes that's a very
good one I wish I had the answer well so
so one could of easy solution is we
could maybe agree on a few wise men or
women more likely the other is that we
could look at consensus in other words
the things on which many humans agree I
think are more likely to be what we
would like our wise AI to follow in
terms of value but but clearly this
required is going to require a lot more
thought shameless block this is what I'm
going to talk about the world alright
one more question I'm so lucky
hi Raman our Kumar perhaps a simple
question what the first factor that you
said was important for the success of
deep learning was lots and lots of data
yes yeah and I wanted to know whether
it's not just deep learning it's any
machinery interfere for all of machine
learning so I want to know if you
foresee any bottleneck in generating
data or whether this is basically solved
by like other problems where the
generation of data will be a bottleneck
or is that a solved problem I'm not sure
to totally understand the question we
have already lots of data I think what I
think it's being generated by the by
like people in the world but it's also
can be generated by machine might exist
by itself and rhinovirus what do we need
we get more and more agents acting in
the world of course we're going to get a
lot more of that kind of data so I'm not
concerned about the existence of that
data and you know we have a lot we'll be
generating more it's more of our ability
to take advantage of it right now which
is which is the bottleneck okay
are we going to switch the speakers if
your lucky day one more question one
more question
well a proposed data question I think we
want to develop intelligent machines
that the engineering of intelligence but
we want to understand also human
intelligence yes the signs of
intelligence yes and you know its eyes
developing does not have as many I have
not seen until two years old as many
images that are in the imagenet database
and certainly with legs I'm not sure
about that partner very kebapi the
diversity for sure not exactly no labels
yes yes yeah and so there is a lot we
have to understand in terms of
technology of unsupervised learning or
supervised learning
yeah I think this is a great question so
that's why I'm I'm insisting a lot on
our need to make progress in learning
more abstract representations because
and abstract representations that are
good at modeling the world understanding
the world that's what allows the child
to to take advantage of the little
amount of data that she sees in her you
know couple of first few years in order
to generalize from very few labeled
examples so of course transfer learning
Smiths provides learning are pretty
important in the research and deep
learning but we need to do a lot better
than we're currently doing there's some
pretty exciting new work going on in
school learning to learn or meta
learning actually following some work
that my brother and I did 20 years ago
where we were actually able to train
systems to to learn to learn from their
actual example and that's I think a very
interesting car all right thank you very
much dajin of your business
you
[Music]